I walk in the rain with style an
umbrella designed by british fashion
label Alexander McQueen one unusual
feature is the handle it was made with a
3d printer it was produced by christiana
ruseva and christian hatem from the
berlin design studio Boyd I think it's
quite decent considering that it's it's
it's really pretty you don't notice that
it's when you printed in terms of
quality it's comparable to traditionally
manufactured product and that's really
what what we aim for it's part of the
new Alexander McQueen winter collection
the British label has always been
provocative now has something of a cult
following
the designer umbrella sells for 450
Europe's making a handle for the
umbrella was just one of many jobs that
void has carried out for the fashion
industry in recent years the Bulgarian
German design duo have made quite a name
for themselves with their 3d printed
designs so they approached us with this
idea of an umbrella handle which they
couldn't currently realize with their
other manufacturing technologies and
which we ended up manufacturing with 3d
printing and 3d scanning the imprint of
a hand served as a template for the
handle traditional manufacturing would
have required an expensive mold but
crystianna vuch eva is working with a 3d
computer model hundreds of tiny details
had to be set before the handle could go
into volume production in silver-plated
brass I mean it's not easy it's most
things that we do are not done yet or
they need the process just need to be
developed because it's a new technology
which is constantly changing constantly
improving new features are being
introduced all the time void began
testing ways to make designer jewelry
using 3d printing in 2014 in the process
they've worked with various designers
[Music]
the British House of flora label is one
of them
[Music]
you can achieve shapes and forms and
really complex structures that are
pretty much unachievable or extremely
difficult with traditional manufacturing
technologies like all these geometric
shapes and interlink elements they
pretty much exist thanks to the 3d
printing technology this brooch by us
Carolina Herrera brand is one example it
was produced using this printer and
selective laser sintering fine layers of
powder our first placed one over the
other a laser then melts the powder at
the right places to produce the desired
form in polyamide 12 plastic the
printing process takes several hours the
broach then has to be removed from the
rest of the powder and cleaned up
[Music]
the designers are constantly testing new
materials for use in their products we
have the ambition to advance the
material spectrum and are working on
this permanently a couple of things that
you can look at as transparent materials
multicolor materials or even multi
material object meaning that you have
multiple materials in one object
integrated since the accessories are all
produced individually they are often
used as style elements in fashion shows
last year void produced an oversized
belt buckle for Belgian label AF
vandevorst
same year they also printed rings that
can be adapted to suit individual
outfits in a collection for the Swiss
label akris
the Berlin designers say it's the future
prospects of this technology that make
it really exciting for me personally
it's it's definitely that we are at the
beginning of this technology and that
it's going to impact all of our lives
substantially in the future and we are
kind of at the forefront of what is
happening what is going to be happening
in many other industries in the future
the stylish Alexander McQueen umbrella
from a 3d printer cutting-edge
technology for a classic accessory
[Music]